même la sénatrice merci ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'agriculture
monsieur le ministre
depuis 15 jours les agriculteurs
subissent de plein fouet les
conséquences de l incendie de lusine
lubrizol à rouen en normandie et en
picardie plus de 900 exploitations
agricoles sont à l'arrêt près de 700
mille litres de lait sont détruits
chaque jour pour un coût déjà supérieur
à 3 millions d'euros
les agriculteurs attendent avec
impatience et appréhension les résultats
des analyses des suis retombé sur le sur
les sols vous les annoncé pour la fin de
semaine
mais pour eux chaque jour qui passe est
un jour de trop et plus grave à ce jour
pas un centime de leur a été versée vous
comptez faire payer le pollueur mais en
attendant c'est à la solidarité
nationale de prendre le relais monsieur
le ministre
cette nouvelle crise intervient alors
que les agriculteurs étaient hier dans
la rue pour crier leur détresse
malgré leurs efforts considérables
depuis 30 ans pour bâtir une agriculture
durable et de qualité
la grille bashing qu'ils subissent et
insupportable si l'on y ajoute la loi et
galim qui n'a rien changé à leur
situation
vos tergiversations à bruxelles qui font
craindre pour l'avenir de la pac et
l'inquiétude dans laquelle vous les avez
plongé avec le traité c'est à je vous
pose cette question simple yat il
quelqu'un dans ce gouvernement qui
défendent encore nos agriculteurs et qui
croient encore en l'agriculture
française merci